[Music]
everyone talking about hunger games
today huge massive hit historic hit in
the movie business one thing I found
interesting cuz I saw the movie over the
weekend is in the movie The Hunger Games
Stanley Tucci's role as a futuristic
evil talk-show host he's yeah I looked
at that rule and I thought this has a
very familiar feel to it take a look so
pizza tell me is there a special girl
back home no no not really no I don't
believe it for a second look at that
face handsome man like you right folks
[Applause]
[Music]
good for you yeah yeah you're in one of
the biggest movies in history don't you
remember when I had that hair like that
for a few months no I do now
thank you knock